Oh, Conan's calling.
Yo, how's it going?
>> Hey, pretty good. Um, I'm just getting a
little set up myself, but you know,
you're more than welcome to talk if you
want to.
>> Um, yeah, no worries. Um, okay.
So, I thought, we should make clear we
had this talk organized before you had
that massive stream yesterday.
>> Yeah.
>> This is not in respon. This is not
response.
>> I'm probably
>> You're uh
>> Yeah, I'm I'm probably going to do a
little bit of like a snark tour or
whatever. But part of the reason why I'm
doing that isn't because I'm trying to
go around and be like, "Oh, I hate
Destiny. Here's everything wrong with
him."
It's just because it's like,
I don't know. Can we have a sane
conversation about all the that's going
on?
Um yeah, makes sense. Uh sorry, two
seconds. I'm just figuring out my
>> and sorry
set up. But um basic basically what I
would do it, you know, if I was running
the conversation, not that I am, uh but
if I was, I would play a quick game of
never have I ever and then I would just
talk about whatever you wanted to talk
about.
>> Um
sure. Okay. And and never have I You
mean like you say never have I ever like
doxed someone?
>> Yeah, sure. Something like that. But
like that that's a sarcastic because Jay
Stock said he didn't want to do that
which I thought was funny. Right.
>> Um but but I can be very quick about it.
>> So have you have you ever talked poorly
of Destiny in the past?
>> Yes. Incredibly.
>> Okay. Have have you done so in private
and in public for extended periods of
time?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Have you doxed him personally
yourself?
>> No.
Have you been in the room while other
people were doxing his address, name,
and telephone number? And then you
laughed about it. No comment is also an
option here.
>> No, I don't think so. No.
>> Okay. Um, have you docked, swatted, or
have you swatted Destiny?
>> No.
>> Okay. Have you uh doxed, swatted, or
digitally harassed Nathan in any way?
>> No.
>> Have you swatted, doxed, harassed
extended family in any
>> Sorry. Sorry. You just broke up a little
bit.
Uh, have you docked, swatted, or
harassed uh via digital means uh
Destiny's extended family in any way?
>> No.
>> Have you taken homemade pornography that
was leaked onto the internet from
Destiny and sent it to his family
members or Nathan?
>> No.
>> Okay, that that's my that's my game.
>> Okay, that's that's all of them.
>> Uh that's all the ones that I care
about. So, so for instance, like
>> if you've talked about him privately and
publicly for extended periods of time, I
think that's one of the charges that's
been leveraged against you.
>> Yep.
>> Uh and then the doxing, swatting, and
harassment is guilt by stochastic
rhetoric.
>> Yeah. So, so yeah, as far as I
understand, um there is actually it's
like not even being claimed that I know
the people doing it. It's basically like
talking about him contributes to an
environment where Kiwi farmers or dogs
been or whatever it is will go go and do
it. That's as far as I understand that
basically is what it comes down to.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Which I feel like is an insane
unless obviously
>> unless Dan or Destiny just like rape us
in the next month and I ask you all
those questions and you're lying to me
directly and then we have screenshots of
you engaging in those behaviors.
That's the allegation that I've heard so
far. And so that that's what that's what
you would need the permission structure.
You create the permission structure to
rape destiny.
>> Sure. Sure. I mean just to be clear the
permission structure I feel like you
know this is something you were getting
into yesterday. The uh they tried to
spin it around on you and say that you
describing the permission structure in
itself creates a permission structure.
Would you say that's that's true?
>> Yes. That that's why descriptive and
prescriptive has become a meme in the
past 24 to 48 hours. You you do think
so. You think that when Destiny comes
back to you with that chat message where
he's saying um you know he says the
thing that Doobie said about him but
like two more layers removed and about
you. You think that chat message is
accurate?
Correct. But I want to point something
out about this. So Doobie is saying that
regardless of whether or not he thinks
it's good, he thinks this is
descriptively true.
>> Yeah. The same way, the same way that I
would press Destiny that he might not
think that people harass, he might
genuinely think that people harassing
me, harassing my desk or harassing my
family, going after my job, he might
genuinely think that that's bad, but
just by uh describing the situation
sarcastically or whatever, he increases
the chance in which it would happen. The
way that I would point out, the way that
him doxing esports Batman or doxing you
or doxing Jtock or doxing Dubbie, that
obviously increases uh the chances that
you guys will be harmed
>> regardless of whether or not that harm
actually occurs?
>> Sure.
Um,
but but you think just making the
descriptive claim is the creation of the
permission structure? Because I I the
way I would look at it is
>> is Destiny doing the action Destiny
doing the action of doxing and then
justifying it. That is the creation of
the permission structure, not
necessarily just the description of the
situation.
For
>> for me, I'd like to take it one step
further. The creation of the permission
structure has nothing to do with whether
or not the permission structure itself
is true.
>> Right?
>> Okay.
>> Right. So, so for instance, like let's
say, sorry, can I give you an extreme
example just so people can know what I'm
talking about?
>> Let's say that I say uh Hitler's a bad
guy because he killed the Jews uh and he
killed 6 million Jews and I'm creating
the permission structure through which
uh Hitler can be deemed a bad guy and
ultimately killed. Uh just because I'm
describing reality and I'm creating the
permission structure actually has no
bearing on the underlying truth claims.
>> Got you. Okay. Anyway, all right. Let's
uh let's get back uh sort of like to
what I think I wanted to speak about
before that [__] happened yesterday. Um
>> so I mean first of all, how do you feel
since uh since the interview last week?
How do you feel about the reception to
it? Uh I saw Tallybots was saying Queman
thinks you're pathetic. Queen seasoning
he was like a little cow for his
audience. They will hate you Connor and
all this [__] But I saw positive
reception generally to the to the
interview. So I was a bit like
>> even even if you were even if the um
>> well yeah I don't think you give a
you're just like you accept like that's
that's kind of the game. But I mean
that's like it was just like a totally
insane read based on what actually ended
up happening that you know there there
certainly were people that wanted it to
be a local performance that were in my
chat desperate for a local performance
the entire time but I think most people
came away with a positive view.
>> Well number one that's the internet and
um sometimes you're going to get to make
fun of other people when they're having
bad days and sometimes people are going
to be able to make fun of you. You know,
we we all get a turn in the chair. Um,
and you can play defense to minimize
your time in the chair, but honestly,
sometimes you end up cucking yourself to
the point that you end up in the chair
more because you're playing such
aggressive defense to not be in the
chair.
>> Sometimes best take your legs
>> in my opinion. Yeah. And the and the
truth is the truth.
>> Yep.
>> So, also I I'll I'll commend everybody
who made a thumbnail about my divorce. I
look handsome in every single one. So,
thank I heard you saying that on stream.
Yeah,
>> you you could you could have hired that
[__] sweaty thumbnail creator who uh
was, you know, quote unquote transphobic
to Keles.
>> Oh, yeah. But nobody did that or
whatever the [__] they called. Yeah.
>> Um,
okay. So, the reason why I messaged you
to talk was because you said on stream
it was about you were watching the the
EI Israel uh clip and you you said
there's a straw man version of this, a
steelman version of this. I'd be
interested to talk to Queen about it and
so I was like my ears pricked up and I
was like okay we'll have another talk
then it sounds great. Um so do you want
to just sort of lay out sort of what
your thoughts were there and we can we
can go into it.
>> Yeah. So so the the straw man version of
it is you're you're you know just a Nazi
or whatever like I watched your
coverages of your coverage of Hutch's
coverage which was funny which was like
oh Queenman's just a groper Nazi fan of
Adolf Hitler.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's funny.
>> Yeah. And um he he oh and then I I got I
got reminded of the the doctor Kanye
West bit. That was pretty funny. But the
um but the steelman version of it is
more interesting to me because you have
claimed to be Jewish in the past.
>> Uh yep. Yep. Ethnically, not
religiously. I should be very clear. Not
raised in any way religious.
>> Was your was your mom ethnically was Was
she raised in the synagogue or something
or or what? Um, I don't want to go I
don't want to go into too much detail
cuz I don't know, you know, it's like
what percentage people are Jews in
Britain? Like, do I want to say too much
about, you know, if I start narrowing
things down at all, I get a bit pranky
about that, especially with extended
family. So, I won't go into that too
much, but I'll just say I'm firmly
atheist. I've always been theally firmly
atheist. Never raised with any religious
influence whatsoever, basically.
>> Okay. Well, hold on. So, well, actually,
that's kind of funny, too. Um, so you
weren't you were you raised in a church
or a synagogue?
>> No. No. Uh when I say my parents raised
me, I think my my mom was always sort of
more agnostic. My dad was firmly
atheist. Uh that's the way I was raised
was firmly atheist.
>> And you didn't you didn't attend any
church or go to any Sunday school or
anything like that?
>> Church. I went to like sort of
maybe like church related events that
were basically just places to send kids
for like an afternoon or whatever the
[__] you know, not actual worship [__]
in any way, you know, literally just
like [__] off for an afternoon sort of
thing. Basically, that's my extent of
engagement with religion and [__] that I
was, you know, that was in school as
well.
>> Okay. Then the Okay. So, so you don't
have any kind of based off of that
upbringing, what kind of affinity or
non-affinity do you have for the state
of Israel?
>> Um, I have I would say I had go going
into Okay, this is probably the best way
to put it. um obviously I've had
throughout my life
um explained to me like you know oh you
know ex you know thing happened and
that's where we all came over and there
was the war and and all this stuff you
know that that was all said to me by
extended family growing up and obviously
I I am visibly Jewish I would say so in
I don't know what it's like in America
but this is what I always said this is
why I claim the Jew label even if I
wasn't raised
religiously is, you know, I was always
treated Jewish. You know, I don't know
what it's like in America, but there
were like endless Holocaust jokes, gas
chamber jokes, caseler, [__] like this.
Just like not even like always super
hostile, but just like that's, you know,
how British schools kind of are. People
rip on. Yeah, there's a black kid that
talk make jokes about being black.
Pakistani kid obviously get ripped for
being Pakistani. So, so I claim I claim
the the Jew label 100% because, you
know, I get treated Jewish. You know,
that's so that's just the way I look at
it. Um
>> Well, was that like um was that like a a
badge of pride almost that [__]
people would banter with you for being
Jewish and you would just lean into
>> Yeah. It's it's not just even a badge of
pride or leaning into it. It's just like
it sort of becomes sort of part part of
your identity as what you grow up. You
you end up making jokes about they make
jokes about it and you you're that's
just sort of where you end up fitting in
and you get sort of put towards that.
So, as uh you know, I I got older, I
always sort of like, you know, aware
that like you know, oh, the argument
that obviously super pro-Zionist people
make is, well, if there's another
Holocaust, Jews need a place to go. So,
I'm always sort of acutely aware when
people say that, that does kind of mean
me that I I would be one of the ones if
there was another Holocaust, right? So,
acutely aware of that going into stuff.
So, sort of I would say that's the level
of affinity I had for Israel was sort of
like the idea that that argument does
kind of pitch to me, right? Not
necessarily that I agree with the
argument or that I care about.
>> I was going to ask uh how did you feel
about that argument as a teenager versus
how do you feel about that argument now?
I don't feel I would say even
around the time of October 7th I
probably had slightly more belief in
that argument but I would never have
actually employed that argument as I
would never have said I believe that you
know it was it's sort of like an
argument I would entertain at this point
I'm like okay I I don't think that's I
don't think having um these ethnostates
is good for anyone I don't think it's
necessary I think Jews are pretty well
integrated into a lot of countries
around the world and
So what what would your be ideal state
of affairs? Because obviously in Eurasia
there's plenty of like ethno religious
center.
>> My ideal state of affairs if if it's
like you know I can I can change the
whole I'm like a you know I'm principal
globalist basically. I would want like
you know the one world government United
Nations whole world government democracy
where anyone can move to wherever they
want and all this [__] That would be
like my principal perfect state of
affairs.
>> Um
>> would it be would it be liberal? Would
it be illiberal?
>> Yeah, it would be liberal. Yeah.
>> Would it be socialist?
>> Um
>> I I I mean I mean sense in a Marxist
>> Yeah. Sure. Explain what you mean by
that. Explain what you mean by that. So,
um I I mean that like uh a lot of
Marxists want the food, water, and
shelter to be free and they want uh you
know workers to have effectively like
some kind of stake in the economic
institutions they participate in. Um so
they reap the rewards. So obviously
there's like market social. There's
10,000 different kinds of socialism, but
decommodification of basic human needs
and workers owning the means of
production is the main thing that I I
identify as socialist. I would say I
don't have a principal commitment to
that. It would depend on because it's
sort of like you know there's the whole
you I'm sure you've heard Vosch talk
about you know the whole like Star Trek
thing the gay space communism post
scarcity [__] or whatever the [__]
>> like I can imagine I can imagine a world
where that's achievable and it's like
well why wouldn't we do that but I'm not
principally like it has to be that way
if there's better outcomes that are
achieved by remaining in a more
capitalist
>> uh uh framework then I would I would
absolutely take the capitalist frame.
Would you would you prefer the um the
United Kingdom's current like mixed
economy capitalist state or the United
States's current mixed economy
capitalist state in my in my estimation
being that like our state has less
welfare programs?
>> Oh, you mean mine or yours? You said
>> uh my I think my country while our
welfare programs are huge um
>> you're comparing UK, right? It's UK
versus US, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Basically, uh, where I want
to get to is UK versus U, uh, UK versus
US versus Scandinavia. What What's a
society you would live in?
>> Probably Scandinavia.
>> Okay. So, so you would be like a social
democrat if
>> I'm a social democrat right now. That's
how I describe myself. Probably social
democrat. Yeah.
>> Okay. Sorry. I'm just I'm so used to
just listening to you talking [__] about
random people that I just don't think
I've heard you articulate politics for
more than five or 10 minutes or it's
like domestic politics for the first
like 30 to 40 minutes of your stream.
And for me that's not like uh that point
of interest. So yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well well so let let's go to
e Israel then. So you're atheist
agnostic. you had a mild ethnic affinity
for the state as its existence. October
7, 2023 happens and then uh in the past
nine months, you joined a discord where
the joking or non-joking
affiliation according to Dan Saltman
>> is hating Ethan Klein, hating Destiny,
and hating Israel. How do we get there?
>> Okay, how how do we get there? Okay, let
me let me try and think back and lay
this out. So
initially after October 7th, I I
believed Israel had a license to engage
in military action to secure their
defenses to to make sure that they are
safe. Now the moment it happened and
they started doing stuff and the
rationale was to destroy Hamas, I was
immediately saying, even though I was
still sort of supportive, that that's
essentially a blank check. That just
sounds like war on terror [__] that is
like, you know, there is no way to ever
truly stamp out this this uh
organization or whatever incarnation of
this organization comes after. You know,
ultimately you can't just solve these
situations through endless violence and
destroying the opposition because that
hasn't worked historically. Um so that
that was my mindset, but still
supportive and was like if there was
going to be like limited strikes or
whatever, yeah, cool, cool, go for it. I
understand the country won't defend
itself. as time's gone on rec seeing
that blank check realized um learning
more about uh
not even like I I don't want to say like
the history because not a lot of my
analysis really I don't really care that
much about like oh who's right or wrong
in the history because it's just about
what what the outcomes are but more more
just about why a lefty would say
something like um you genocide is a
necessity to the existence of of Israel.
that like you know the way that uh stuff
like the Nakbush shook out um that
that's made me realize oh okay when you
have these hard principled commitments
to maintaining an ethnic majority it
does require you to according to
ethnicity displaced people ma uh
maintain a um a majority through sort of
like secondass
um treatment under law that this does
kind of just flow from the principal
commitment to the ethnic majority and
that's a problem. So, so I've become
more sympathetic to that that view over
time that just simply
>> how do you how do you feel about the uh
liberal Zionist Hazbara
the propaganda that 20% of the citizens
of Israel are Arab Muslim Palestinians
and are there therefore it's not an
ethnoreigious state? Uh yeah, I think
that's totally [__] because it's
about whether you have it's it's not
about whether you have some people of
whatever background in in your state. If
there are laws that discriminate
according to ethnicity, saying either it
has to be this amount or you can't do
this if you're or you you get extra
rights if you're you know anything along
these lines or any um defense of
institutions that that are designed to
do that even if they don't state it
explicitly is you are still supporting
an ethnostate. you're still supporting
ethnos supremacy whatever it be in that
in that particular description
>> is that like uniquely vile to you like
like so for instance like uh just like
an American perspective a lot of
Americans come from a variety of places
in Europe but also from you know Africa,
the Middle East, North Africa and Asia
and so like ethno religious u heritage I
suppose is something that like you know
it kind of affects the way that we
interact with each other but
realistically
It's more of like where we raz each
other. I I guess we we like give each
other [__] similar to how you were
talking about how like black Pakistani
Jewish and British English kids give
each other [__]
>> Yeah.
>> Um so so so I guess my question is like
is any kind of ethnoreigious affinity
repulsive to you or is it just when it
becomes enforced by the state? Yeah, I
think I think it's mainly just like I
don't think um people feeling an
affinity for their background or their
heritage or anything is is is wrong or
or repulsive to me. It is just trying to
um yeah affect other people according to
their or give yourself benefits
according to your you know it's it's
when it when it becomes when it actually
plays out in practice that's that's the
problem you know where it plays out in a
way that affects other people or could
dis disadvantage them.
So, so do you think uh what's happened
in Gaza um and then you can
differentiate of course I expect you to
be smart enough to do so. Um but how
would what words would you use to
describe what's happened and happening
in Gaza, what's happening in southern
Lebanon, south Latutani River and what's
happening in the West Bank/Jude and
Samaria?
>> You're saying for for I assume starting
for Gaza, you're saying would I call it
a genocide? Is that the question?
Basically,
>> yes.
>> Uh, yes. I think I would call it a
genocide at this point.
>> Can I can I ask like uh why or how or
what's the mechanism that you came to
that judgment with?
>> So, I'm not the you I'm not a [__]
international law guy. I don't claim to
be. Um, I read I I I was very hesitant
to use the word at all for a long time
because I'm such a, you know, I am like
I'm not an international law guy.
But I respect international law guys and
I and I think that is a good way to
analyze things. Um,
and I know I'm too [__] you know,
layman to to truly make a determination,
but I read this Beast Process article
breaking down Laner Box's takes on
genocide recently, and that sort of uh
clarified a few things in my mind about
how it it it tends to be evaluated, and
it's
primarily it's it's about
the
and I'm going to butcher the arguments
Here I'm going to totally butcher the
arguments. I'm like so hesitant to ever
talk anything to do with international
law. I'm going to to I'm going to
totally butcher this. Um
it's about the I I don't believe they
have taken precautions or actions to
prevent genocidal acts and there have
been repeated statements in incitement
and I think orders given tactics
deployed by Israeli officials that I
can't see a way
around the idea that that they've wanted
that to happen and have been pushing
that on. um that can I give you the uh
tepid zionist apologia?
>> Sure, go for it.
>> So my question is, you know, the the
calculated I'm always asking people for
updated casualty stats. But whenever I
Google the casualty stats, it's
estimated that 200,000 indirect deaths
uh as a result of the conflict and
70,000 deaths uh is where we've been at
for the past like year. And when I think
of the word genocide, because partially
I was raised on your people's
propaganda.
>> You think you killed more than six
million?
>> Well, right. It's, you know, you you
line them up, you dig a giant, you know,
ditch, you line them all up, you shoot
them in the back of the head, you throw
their bodies in the ditch, you throw lie
on it, and then you throw dirt on top of
it. That's one way. Um, you know, the
other way is, you know, throwing them
down into a gas chamber and then gassing
them and throwing them.
>> I mean, my understand to too strict a
definition of genocide that that it's
not about whether you're uh killing them
all. It's it's the deliberate
destruction of a a people in whole or in
part, you know. So, you you could only
genocide 100 Palestinians and it would
still be a genocide, you know. It's it's
it's about
>> Yeah. Well, and I guess that gets back
to what you were saying was the intent
like the the stated intent was part of
your motivation for labeling it a
genocide.
>> Uh yeah. Yeah.
>> Because basically they said, "Oh yeah,
we because part of the UN definition as
far as I understand it is like uh it's
also bringing about living conditions
that are supposed to in whole or in part
end."
>> And then there's Yeah. So when I say
about tactics and stuff of like um
targeting like the IVF clinic where like
I don't see what what is the what was
the military objective to targeting the
IVF clinic other than to basically
prevent the continuation of this people
in whole or in part you know that that
just seems like you know when you've
destroyed why why do you have to destroy
like every school that's basically
destroying a generation of this pe this
people's education you know it's it's a
it is a just continued sort like
destruction of the culture and identity
and living conditions of this this
people that seems to that seems to be
only driven by the want to be rid of
that people.
Would you uh would you call me a Zionist
dick sucker if I said that uh I think
that you can establish like like the
genocide thing. It calls back to me the
Holocaust. I don't think that the
Israelis are engaged in industrial
slaughter at this time. Uh but I do
think that they have BB Netanyahu in
particular has uh pretty much clearly
stated that he intends to ethno
religiously I think you need to add in
the religion part of that um to
ethnoreigiously cleanse uh southern
Lebanon, Gaza, and Judea and Samaria. Um
so do you think that I'm like a I'm
sweeping for the the Zog government by
sanitizing my terms?
Um, yeah, I I think that's probably
sweeping. I think that's probably
sweeping for for Zog.
>> Okay. Um, you know, I mean, I identify
as a tepid Zionist, so that might just
be true. Um, the So, so my question is
like one of the things that is
interesting about the Snark Discord
because this goes back to E Israel and
then obviously you guys are uh under a
lot of public scrutiny right now. um was
that jokingly or not the motivations of
the discord or the how you get in is
like hating Ethan Klein, hating um you
know, Israel, hating destiny. So why why
is Ethan Klene um such a piece of [__]
in your worldview considering back when
he was still talking to Hassan, he was
saying [__] like, "Oh yeah, I agree that
Westbank settlers are valid military
targets." Because for me to see an an
Israeli say that [__] that's crazy.
>> Um, yeah, I agree. Back back in the day
and even sometimes now, Ethan will say
something that seems to be very pro pro
Palestine or very lefty or whatever you
want to call it. He will say something
that's that seems to be that way. But
when you look at the sort of like lion
share of his coverage and what what what
message comes across on his podcast for
the past two years, the message that has
come across is lefties are crazy. Bro
Pali people are crazy. Israel's not that
bad. Israel defenders aren't that bad.
And you should you should be nicer to
Jews. And that is just the message of
the podcast for the whole last
>> Why is that? Can can I maybe I could
write that down or something? It's like
lefties are crazy.
Uh, palis are or pali pro palies, sorry,
are crazy.
>> Um, and then not all Israelis are evil.
Well, it's not even just not all
Israelis are evil. It's just Israel's
not that bad, right? Generally, it's
like, you know, he he will just he'll
say about how, oh, Israel's so diverse.
You guys need to see how progressive it
really is and all this [__] It's just
like bizarre.
>> Yeah. But doesn't um Sorry, I'm I'm
gonna do some Ethan Klein apology here
real quick. Um, so for instance, like uh
a lot of the charges are like uh ethnic
cleansing, right? But then one of the
arguments, which by the way, I I think
still covers up a lot of bad behavior,
but you know, the uh Jewish population
that's in there is not exclusively
Ashkanazi. I think it's like 60 to 70%
Ashkanazi, but then the remainders are
like McGrebie and Mizrahi and Ethiopian
and all that kind of [__] So, I think
what they're trying to say is like, you
guys are accusing us of being like
goostepping [__] Nazis, but we have
our own version of like black and brown
Jews and we don't have beef with each
other. Yeah. I just don't think that's
at all relevant or responsive because
it's not the line that's being drawn,
right? Is about Jews. That's that's the
line they draw. don't draw. You know,
you can say, "Oh, Israel's progressive
because there's lots of different types
of Jews." But fundamentally, it's being
progressive or progressive isn't about
sort of how wide or or numerous your
identity group is. It's about how you
treat people of other identity groups.
Um, and then they do that.
>> Well, what what if they say, "Well, you
know, my my buddy Ahmed is an Israeli
citizen and we're best friends, you
know, like I have I have a black." may
be able to point to one progressive
Israeli who has a black friend or
whatever, but the the the point is about
sort like the polling. Generally, Ethan
saying this in response to people
implying that the Israeli population is
like a fascist population. And if you
look at the polling and what they think
of uh key issues about about their
military, about the government, yeah,
it's not a reasonable thing unreasonable
thing to say. They've got a massively
fascistic population who believe in a uh
uh ethnosuppreist mindset.
Okay. The I mean I just accept that
descriptively because like um I I'm
sympathetic to the Hazbara or whatever,
but I also understand how a leftist
would re be repulsed by I have an Arab
Muslim best friend, but we must
ethnreligiously cleanse southern
Lebanon.
>> Yeah.
>> Like like I understand why they would be
upset by that. Now, uh, one two of the
things that you said though were like
lefties are crazy and pro palies are
crazy. So, one thing that I think is
crazy is I think Dubbie, um, who has
either me'd into this position or he's
serious about it. Um, I can't tell
depending on the day. Um he's saying
that he tentoes down in line with Assan
[__] supports the Red Sea crisis, but
that involves like missile striking and
drone striking random civilian
commercial vessels which have resulted
like a half dozen to a few dozen deaths.
>> Um you mean
>> regardless of blockade?
>> Yes. Yes, I do.
>> Um so so I find that crazy. Um but how
do you feel about uh regardless of the
moral loading of the word terrorism? I'm
just talking about like the strict
definition of like extraleal killings of
civilians in the name of a political,
ideological, or religious goal. Uh,
regardless of the moral loading of the
term, how do you feel about like uh
Houthy terrorism in the name of trying
to stop the Gausen genocide?
>> Yeah. So, I I'm not like hugely read up
on everything the Houthies did as part
of the blockade and so I wouldn't take
like any firm position here. However,
I have a lot of sympathy for the
argument that when international law has
broken down for a certain group of
people, it's kind of bizarre to get up
in arms at the at the at the group that
now attempt to institute it for that
group of people. You know, now that the
only the only group attempting to stop
this in any forceful way, you're like,
"Wow, that's terrible because uh
terrorism." And it's just a mindset that
only benefits state actors, only
benefits the most powerful. and you
basically just lead to the underdog
getting raped every time.
>> Okay. Well, just just doing an extreme
hypothetical though. Let's say that
there was uh [__] I'm probably going to
butcher this, but [__] it. I'll try. Um
let's say that there was like a serial
killer in my city. And I know analogies
always get messy, but just bear with me
for a second. Um let's say there's a
serial killer in my city, and people are
not doing enough. He's literally killed
dozens of people. But then what I do is
I find a hooker who has nothing to do
with the situation and I shoot her in
the face in broad daylight. And then I'm
going to get arrested for that
obviously. But then I say, "Hey guys,
the reason why I killed this random
person was because I wanted to draw your
attention to the serial killer that is
going unressed
in our society."
So I I don't I don't know that this is I
don't know that this is a perfect
analogy because
>> it's probably not. It's off the top of
my head. So be very
>> here's uh sort of my problem there is
that my understanding is that the idea
was a a blockade to prevent supplies
economic benefits uh headed to Israel
basically or or in that area. And when
they the galaxy leader people contested
that it was headed for Israel and all
this stuff. My understanding is that
ultimately at the top of the parent
company, it was owned by Israeli. Um,
>> see, my my frustration with this and you
know is I feel like Hassan [__] who
I'm a huge critic of, um, capitalizes on
the ignorance and sanitization of these
incidents in order to make them more
popular than they otherwise would be.
Um, so for instance, you can just go to
the Wikipedia page on the Red Sea crisis
and you can see the dozens of ships that
have been uh attacked either by missile,
by drone or by helicopter with uh Yemen
special forces, which is obviously not
very special, but uh these these tankers
are not Israeli. They're not even
American. Weirdly enough,
>> the Galaxy Leader is the one that I've
heard disputed the most, and they say
that that one is owned by an Israeli.
Well, will you will you begrudge me if I
think that uh the galaxy leader is being
used by uh for propagandistic reasons
because that might have been the one
that the Houthies actually researched in
order to attack, but realistically
they've attacked dozens of other uh
commercial.
>> That may be the case, but the one that
always gets argued over and the one that
people attack Assan for supporting and
playing the video of is the Galaxy
Leader. Um so that's the that's the one
that everyone always engages on. So I
would I would I would agree here.
I will take a I will take a position uh
here which is that
>> I would I support
>> basically stuff like the galaxy leader
in principle if if there is a
wellressearched not necessarily saying
that I know all the information here but
if there is a wellressearched target
selected um you know instance where they
they are actually targeting something
that will be an economic benefit to
Israel for the purpose of basically
imposing a blockade or sanctions as a
non-state actor. That's the sort of
thing where I look at it and I go,
"Yeah, I kind of get support in this. I
do kind of get support in this at once
international law is broken down, it's
clear that uh there's no recourse for
this group of people. There's no no
one's stepping in." Um
>> Okay.
>> However, targeting civilian target um
sorry, not civilian, I say civilian, but
non non-affiliated vessels, stuff like
that, I I would be against. And and the
issue is I'd accept as well that the
issue with supporting stuff like that is
that um when it's a non-state actor or
when it's non-regulated, the chances
that they're just going to focus on
affiliated actors is is quite low.
They're probably going to be bad at
target selection. They're probably not
going to research everything. They're
probably going to be self-interested in
many ways. And so you shouldn't broadly
support terror groups doing this sort of
thing.
Okay, that that's where uh I'm just
going to tell you part of my criticism
of Hassan [__] and uh the people who
like him, follow him, apologize for him,
etc., etc., is the fact that I feel like
uh correct me if I'm wrong, the Galaxy
whatever. Uh part of the reason why that
uh he showed that is because they
videotaped a helicopter boarding
mission.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. and and so so that obviously had
uh few or no casualties
uh you know it was the Yemenes flexing
that they had a capacity to do so uh etc
etc. Um my frustration with that is I
feel like it's effectively a lie of
omission where they're ignoring the 30
or 40 other civilian commercial vessels
that have been attacked. Um they're
ignoring the half dozen to a dozen
people who have been killed and I feel
like they're sweeping uh for those
actions. So I understand I mean Hassan
is an open propagandist who I'm certain
that the motivation there is that
ultimately Israel is the greater evil
and whitewashing this group in response
to the massive media whitewashing of
Israel is justified. I'm sure I'm
certain that would be roughly the
perspective and and yeah, but when if
you actually try to evaluate the truth
of it, yes, I'm sure that most of these
are not justified if you actually aren't
doing a very good job of creating a
blockade.
>> For for me, um, one of the things that
you asserted that was like bad about
Ethan Klene was that he part of his
grand narrative is that lefties are
crazy. Um, I agree with the sentiment
that lefties are crazy based off of what
we just described. Um, if you'll indulge
me, uh, moving to and if you have Yeah.
So, I'll stop you right there. I
understand why you would think lefties
are crazy. You're a neocon. Ethan Klein
wants to be treated as a lefty and say
lefties are crazy and then argue against
and demean and attack every lefty
position. So, that that's the difference
there, Con. I don't I don't I don't hear
you say lefties are crazy and think,
"What so absurd Connor is saying that?"
You're a neocon. Of course, you think
that.
>> Sure. No, I mean honestly I I straight
up think because I I have been doxed uh
as a result of the PB leaks and I I
think there's plenty of people who
dislike me, but I straight up think that
the reason why I've gotten substantially
less harassment than a lot of other
people is because I'm not like like I
openly say, "Yeah, sure. I'm like
capital L liberal, but Democrats piss me
off and I don't identify as a Democrat."
And then leftists and I are just [__]
oil and water. So I don't I don't I'm
not a traitor. I'm just like a rival or
an enemy. Sure. And therefore I deserve
less scorn.
>> Sure. Yeah. Yeah. I think that's
probably true.
>> Okay. Well, with with Pal's um I
appreciate you calling that out. I think
it's true. Um with pali's being crazy,
just showing how I agree with Ethan
Klein, which probably hurts Ethan
Klein's case actually, uh but it's still
funny. With Pie's being crazy, the two
things that I can cite that off the top
of my head are uh pornographic actress
Mia Khalifa stating, "Can somebody
please tell the brave fighters to turn
their videos uh vertical to horizontal?"
And this is why while they're like
uploading [__] beheading videos and
civilians getting massacred. Uh for
Froggen, um I understand that she was
being descriptive, but I still thought
it was a [__] wild thing to say on
the day of. Uh she said something akin
to leftists always crow for a revolution
but when they see one in the Middle East
and North Africa all they have is
criticism. This is what it looks like.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I mean is that a little crazy?
I feel like that's crazy.
>> Um
>> yeah that's not so the the issue I have
there is you're picking out two
examples. Say this side is crazy. You
can do that with both sides, right? You
could pick any number of Zionist tweets
out from the same same day and have the
same opinion. But Ethan had the reaction
to one side and then made his coverage
all about one side when you can actually
you actually can just choose which side,
you know, you're criticizing and pick
the crazy people out. That's like, you
know, because there's there's people
saying just as crazy or crazier [__]
than that on on both sides, you know.
Isn't Isn't Hassan actually this is a
great question. Um, isn't Hassan a uh
Arab Muslim majority one stater?
>> Isn't Hassan what? Sorry.
>> Isn't Hassan [__] The reason why I'm
bringing up specifically is obviously he
was Ethan Klein's friend at the time and
a lot of his community is probably going
to share the sentiment. Isn't he a
majority Arab Muslim? Meaning that
effectively like the state would become
Palestine. it would become a democracy.
Uh and then if the Jews were a ethnic
religious
I don't I think he principally believes
that it should be that majority right he
just thinks it that that would probably
be the descriptive that's how it would
shake out but I don't think he believes
in a principled commitment to that
majority right
>> but but
as a matter of process that would be the
abolition of the state of Israel right
>> yes
>> that would yeah Israel as I understand
it is the is a like you know Israel
entails being a Jewish state in the
Leavant. That's, you know, that's
>> So, so my uh my question then is uh so
Ethan Klein has representative
represented himself
as an anti-ionist,
but within the definitional framework
that we're working with. uh he wants a
Israel to basically freeze their
borders, pull all the settlers back and
then, you know, just have like a
two-state solution
>> and that that's what he wants. Uh but I
think I have even heard you recently say
that he is like a gigazionist. So So how
come like a two-stater who wants to
freeze the borders is being treated the
same as like an expansionist? So I would
say it's it's in the reason why I would
say Ethan Klein is I don't know if I
would say exactly Giga Zionist or what
but the reason why I would say he's like
a fervent Zionist or something like that
is in the way he delivers his criticisms
the criticisms he chooses to deliver
because he's yes he believes all those
things. He doesn't exactly harp on about
them. He does believe he does seem to
believe all those things that they
should pull back.
Um, however, he is very committed to the
Jewish majority from what I can tell.
Uh, he's very defensive of that. He's
very defensive of anything that's sort
of entailed by that. Uh, and and and so
in in the rhetoric that he's using and
the points he's defending, I think it
comes across as being quite a fervent
Zionist, even if you don't believe in
the expansionist uh broader broader
definition, if you know what I mean.
Because there like two Zionist
definitions almost like Zionist like
>> you know Zionist as it is definitionally
and then Zionist
>> in the sense of like a specific
political group that believe in like
expansionism and [__] Well and do do
you think that Zionist is a uh in so far
as to saying like the nation state of
Israel has a right and should exist to
be a uh Jewish majority nation state?
Uh, is that a sufficient belief to be
labeled a Zionist in your mind?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And then are you anti-ionist in
that you think in an ideal world this
state of Israel would be abolished and
it would be a secular state?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Um,
do you Okay. Do you understand Ethan
Klein's perspective? Even if you think
he's a piece of Well, I don't want to
say a piece of [__] Do you think he's a
piece of [__] Do you think he earnestly
believes it and he's just incorrect? Uh
what what do you think? What do you
think about Ethan Klein?
>> I think Ethan Klein is a total piece of
[__] Um
>> what do I list the reasons off and is it
just because of Israel Palestine or is
the reason?
>> No, it's not just because of Israel
Palestine. So, I honestly just being a
Zionist on its own, what it's like being
a racist or something. Like, yeah, it's
bad, but like I I I don't really I'm not
really impassioned about hating that
person just on that one fact alone. You
know, there's there's a lot of racists
out there. There's a lot of Zionists out
there. You know, you you don't really
get impassioned to hate someone just off
of that. Uh Ethan Klein's personal
conduct is far more determinative. in me
hating him than his his like beliefs,
his political beliefs.
>> Um,
>> is it well, how much would you say the
personal conduct issue is related to uh
lawsuits and the nukes uh versus any
other conduct that you can think of?
>> Yeah, I'd say the lawsuits
>> like how much of your hatred is the
lawsuits?
>> The lawsuits are a huge amount of it.
the lawsuit compile probably
>> and uh I I remember this from some of
your older content. So you were kind of
like a I don't want to say like a Kiwi
farmer or whatever, but you were like a
free speech sympathetic
[__] poster on the internet. So part of
what you admired about Destiny back in
the old days was the fact that he was
taking the fight to Keles.
>> Yes. Yeah. And that's what that's what
>> was there was there anything else that
made you a fan of his? Um,
yeah. I mean, obviously I like uh I like
debate stuff. I like seeing someone who
performs well in debates. I I used to
watch, you know, like a kill stream a
whole bunch. Um, I liked all the blood
sport stuff. So, so it was just like
that. That's sort like content I was I
was a big fan of. Um, and then Destiny
most closely aligned with my political
beliefs and then especially I was I was
invested in the the careful stuff and
and when you backed off on that that was
really when I was like okay this guy
kind of plays.
>> So that um that dislike
uh to put it mildly has solidified over
the past few years I suppose. Yeah. Uh,
are there additional what what are the
additional things that have made you
dislike him so voseiferously besides the
backing off on digitally strangling
Keffles?
>> Yeah. So, it's just the uh the personal
conduct and the lying about it as well.
Those are the those are the biggest
things other than um any abandonment of
the Keles sort of principles that he
had. And can you can you elaborate
because just as an example, um I said
that and Stephen scoffed at this. Uh he
said that or I said that there could be
very legitimate reasons for why people
dislike you or hate you that they
earnestly believe and he was saying that
um no, it's all effectively like
delusional sociopathy. So, what what are
the things that So, on top of not
strangling Keeles in the crib when he
had the chance, uh what are the personal
conduct issues that have made you
dislike him? And also, uh if if if there
was a particularly egregious lie?
>> Yeah. So, I I was one of the people
[__] enough to believe what he was
spending about Anna and enjoying that
content at the time. And so, when I saw
when it all came together, uh I was
like, "Oh, wow. This guy's like kind of
a total piece of shit." Obviously, he
denies that one. or he has his own uh
narrative about what happened there. I
heard him say on stream something like,
"Oh, if you showed that to anyone in
real life, they wouldn't give a fuck."
And that's just like totally delusional.
Anyone that watched that stuff play out,
even without knowing like all the
context, just knowing what Destiny
presents to stream would probably be
like, "Oh, this guy's kind of [__]
crazy." Um, well, I want to I want to
make a differentiation u and and it's
something that I don't expect you to
sign on to, but I'll state it anyways.
So, with Anna, uh, one of my criticisms
that I've made known for a really long
time is that I think that Steven engages
with mentally ill women.
>> Sure.
>> Uh, he should know that they're mentally
ill relatively quickly. Uh, they become
infatuated with him because he's
charismatic and funny and smart. My
opinion, doesn't have to be yours. Um,
and but then when they're a pain in the
ass, he's kind of like, "Okay, I'mma dip
out." And then that drives them [__]
crazy. Uh, and if they don't move on and
they make themselves part of the
content, then he will use them for
content. Um, I think that's been true
descriptively, especially with Anna uh
and Lavlin. So, that that's my criticism
of him. But then my frustration, too, is
I feel like the snarkers don't give any
agency to the women. Um, so what level
of agency do you give to a character
like Lav or Anna or I'm trying to think
of another?
>> I think those two are very different. I
think those two are very different. Um,
Anna,
>> elaborate, please.
>> Anna definitely less agency. Uh,
especially because it it seems
>> on a scale of 1 to 10, could you give us
a rate?
>> Well, it depends at the what point and
what was going on at the time. She has
certain certain, you know, there are
certain things she did that she has more
agency in. There are certain things that
she has less agency in. I couldn't
really
>> What What about uh So what I'm poking at
is her ability to break it off.
>> Um
>> agency do you think you had there?
>> Like like a I I'll just articulate my
three
certain points.
>> Exact I was going to say I felt like she
while she could adult quote unquote in
other parts of her life uh I felt like
her capacity to break off was very low.
>> Yeah. So my feeling about it based on
the evidence is that um there was a
level of willful exploitation of her
specific triggers around this sort of
thing uh for both content and the
continuation of the relationship. Uh
that's how it seems. There are there are
such blogs that I quote all the time
where he's saying where she's begging to
have her reputation fixed. Um, and he
says, "Maybe one day, but for now, I'll
just keep robbing your legs and feet or
some [__] like that." So, it always felt
like there was a bit of a carrot carrot
and stick approach where she was being
both punished and rewarded and strung
along. And that's that's uh kind of
depraved to me. Like, it comes off kind
of [__] insane to me.
>> Okay. Um, how much agency do you give uh
Steven? because while I do find him
incredibly
uh intelligent at times, I do feel like
he's impulsive or compulsive at times.
>> Um yeah, I definitely I you know, I'm
not totally I'm not saying that was an
easy situation for him at every point.
Uh there was definitely a lot of, you
know, she was both
harassing him in certain ways herself
and I'm sure there was stuff coming off
the back of what she was saying that was
causing him problems. Um so I'd say he
wasn't like a 10 agency but he was like
up in he was up above seven.
Okay. So we got uh in my opinion we got
Keles,
we got the Anna situation.
Uh what are the uh do do you have any
feelings? I know that you were maybe are
a friend a fan of uh Mr. Girl.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh what was the um how do you feel about
because obviously from like a content
standpoint it was you know like straight
[__] fire like the 12hour
[__] you know Mr. Girl Lav Lon uh
Destiny struggle sessions like I mean I
enjoyed that content. Yeah, I love if
you
>> I if you think of them as people, it's
obviously like a lot more agonizing. Uh
so do you have any criticisms or hatred
of the Mr. Girl fallout?
>> Any criticisms or hatred of the Mr. Girl
Fallout
>> from the Mr. Girl Fallout? Like as his
fan, did you think that Destiny was like
raping Mr. Girl? Is that one of the
Would that be top five reasons that you
hate him or no?
Um, no. I don't I don't think so. As
much as I like uh Mr. Girl, he's like,
you know, he's prone to falling out with
everyone. He's got one of those
personalities.
Um
I
Yeah, I don't think that any
specific I'd say I'd say it just plays
into other things. It's just like, you
know, the way so like there's the Nuke
stream, right, where he's like
um
he goes on stream to talk about Mr. Girl
and M girl calls in and is basically
like you were still texting Anna, you
were still and then Destiny's obviously
like rattled and freaks out and and get
kicked like kicked like a few minutes
later and he goes and starts on his
crusade after that. Um,
I'd say like stuff like that doesn't it
doesn't make me hate Destiny in and of
itself. It's just like more of him
trying to cover up the Anna stuff, you
know? I just see it as
>> okay
>> as just the the way he was behaving
there was like pure self-preservation,
you know? Nothing there was like crazy
gross in and of itself because it's all
part of other things that he's trying to
get out of.
>> Okay. Well, then I got I got Keeles and
Anna as like um top two so far. What
What would you say would be like another
reason why you dislike Steven Banel the
second extreme?
>> Keles, Anna.
Oh man,
what's another reason?
Well, there's the endless barrage of
doxings aimed at people in my general
vicinity. There's that. That's that's
probably a big one.
>> And call to violence and and all this
[__] the so uh I I would actually like
to deal with that narrative head on
because this is obviously something that
I'm getting in trouble for right now. So
I think the the narrative barring
additional evidence leaked from the
server that shows you or JTO or Dubbie
engaged in explicit gay ops uh personal
identifying uh information operations
uh swatting or doxing or anything like
that. Barring any of that because this
VOD might be watched after he releases
his manifesto or whatever. Um what what
do you think like like what do you think
of the narrative that you guys you and
Jtock in particular um have a creative
hate boner for Destiny? There are a
shitload of people in Twitch and YouTube
politics who also hate Destiny. And so
therefore, by congregating and
constantly talking [__] about him, um
you're creating the stochcastic
structure for him to be doxed and
swatted. Um
I think that if you start um applying
like it could be true in to some extent
that I mean well it is true to some
extent that if you're saying that
descriptively that when you criticize
people online with incredibly cutting
criticism especially when it's related
to sexual impropriate and stuff like
that uh it creates an environment where
stuff where bad things are more likely
to happen. Yes, that is descriptively
true. Um, however, if you start
prescribing that that means you can't do
that, this whole thing breaks down.
>> Well, and so where's the where's the
line for you? So, for instance, like u I
I think I I brought up the example
earlier that like let's say we say
Hitler killed 6 million Jews. Well,
we're clearly creating a permission
structure with which Hitler can be
killed by the Allies, but that doesn't
have any bearing on whether or not the
underlying claim is true.
>> So, where do you draw the line on
cutting criticism of things you believe
to be true versus what you think is
likely to result in I think digital
harassment is probably going to be the
vaguest term that we could contend with
today. Um, but obviously like digital
harassment would probably be the lowest
level of bad thing and then the next
level would probably be like doxing and
then the highest level would be like
swatting or stock IRL stalking. So, so
where where's your line? So, so my my
immediate failing is I mean to ask you
like how exactly you want me to answer
this question, but my immediate failing
is it's like if you're not calling for
and you're moderating against the worst
behaviors,
um I don't I don't know how you can ever
be sort of like in the wrong or going
too far if you're keeping it to true
statements or, you know, jokes and
satire. You know, I to me that's that's
all, you know, I'm I'm a free speech
guy. I think you should, you know, as
long as you're doing your responsibility
to make sure it's not happening around
you, you're not participating in it. I
don't I don't think you should be
stopped from saying basically anything.
So long as it's not, you know,
defamatory or some other issue.
>> How do you feel about these two comments
that I wish I could use the fs slur in
order to describe my own chatters? Um,
so a brainwashing happening live is not
something you see every day. Uh, number
one, do you think that you're
successfully brainwashing me? Uh, and
then number two, uh, magic. Somebody
says they dox Destiny's child lol. So
why do they get a pass for criticizing
Destiny doxing?
>> Oh my god.
>> So, um, you you as this amalgamation
hole. We we did the never have you ever
earlier. Um, but do you want to explain
why you don't think you're responsible
for Destiny's doxing or swatting?
>> Uh, sure. So, let's start with uh the
second one, I guess. So, yeah, they say
they doxed Destiny's Kid. I did not dock
Destiny's Kid, so far as I know. No, you
know who did. No one No, I've got no
idea who do S Destiny's Kid. So far as I
know, nobody in my community has docked
Destiny's Kid. I don't even discuss
Destiny's kid unless it is like
absolutely like blowing up like everyone
is talking about it and Destiny's
already talking about it or something
like that. I stay well away from that
stuff, you know, 99% of the time. Uh I
don't want anything to do with talking
about Nathan. I feel quite bad for
Nathan. I don't to be honest, it's quite
a depressing situation to me. I don't
really want to talk about it. So I I
just don't understand how I could be
ascribed responsibility for things
happening to to to Nathan. I don't that
makes no sense to me. Are are are Dan
are Dan Saltman and Destiny going to be
able to rape you at the last minute when
the manifesto drops?
>> No. No. I I liter I avoid it. I just
avoid it.
>> Okay.
>> You know.
>> All right. And then uh what about the
Washington allegations? Do Do you think
you've said anything?
>> I just want to make sure that I want to
make sure I'm fully clear that you know
I have all my statements out here. I
will comment on things where it's like,
"Oh, apparently Drew Pavlo spoke to
Nathan. That's [__] weird. Apparently
food shops raided into that. Don't know
why that's going on." I'll comment on
things like that, but there has never
been sustained coverage or significant
attention brought to to Nathan. It's
always just things that are already
swirling around in [__]
like, you know, everywhere. No, no one
no one wants to pay significant
attention to him. There was like, for
instance, there was this guy called Joe
Podor. Have you ever heard that name?
>> I haven't.
>> He's sort of like a Joe Red Bar.
>> Okay.
>> Do you know who Redbar is? Have you
heard that name before?
>> I don't. I'm sorry. I I am sorry online,
but I'm this whole world of like these
trolls, okay? They're like these trolls.
They just go around [__] with people
and doing live streams on it. This guy
called Jesse Podor or Jesse PS some [__]
who showed up at like he like I think he
agged Ethan Ralph in real life or
something. He basically just crazy
stuff. And he had like Destiny's kid on
one time and they had like this
conversation where he's proddding him
with all these jokes about his dad's
sexual impropriy, his dad's sexual
fetishes and all this stuff. I always
literally stayed well away from from
anything like that at all points because
that [__] is just like it's just too
far. It's just like obviously over a
line and it's bizarre that you know
anyone engaged with it.
>> The uh so I still have uh gray names.
Sorry that I'm addressing the chat. I
still have gray names in my chat who are
saying that Queen is just lying. So I
just posted my Discord link in the chat.
You are welcome, like like seriously
welcome to go join the Discord, click on
my profile and DM me evidence of uh
Queenman's duplicity. Um I I've been I
asked for Dubbie's duplicity for the
last 30 minutes of or 18 minutes of the
stream on Friday. I got nothing. And so
you likewise have an invitation to send
me uh evidence of [__] uh dubbies
duplicity.
>> So then the the other message was
something about brainwashing you, right?
It was it was do I feel like I'm
>> actually Hold on. Can I share one thing
before we go into brainwashing?
>> Yes, of course. So, I have evidence. I
have screenshot evidence that there is a
telegram group of gropers who actively
plotted to go to Miami to kill Steven
and they thought that they were hyping
each other up to the point that one of
them would do it. I have that evidence.
So, if there are gropers who are willing
to try to hype each other up to go kill
Steven in Miami, would they be willing
to dox or swat him? And I think
logically, inferentially, the answer is
yes.
>> Yeah, probably. So right now I have more
evidence
of gropers attempting to dock, swat or
murder destiny than I have been
presented that Queen and Doobie are
guilty of attempting to dock, swat or
murder Destiny. So if you want to give
me contrary evidence, my Discord link is
open. Sorry for the yap, but I I feel
like that needs to be articulated.
>> Yeah, no worries. Sorry. So the
brainwashing thing as well. So I mean
>> yes brainwashing
>> me and you have literally I feel like
almost every conversation we have had
has been like very
contentious aggressive but pretty much
every time and I don't think there is a
single thing that I have argued to you
that you now 100% believe. I know you
could correct me if if if I'm wrong but
both of both of us are quite stubborn. I
I feel like so I don't feel like this is
really brainwashing.
>> Um
>> I said that I was going to challenge you
and then Briana Woo for whatever reason
said, "Oh yeah, I'd love to challenge
Queenman." And then we let that happen
and that was a moment in internet
history that was very interesting.
>> Um I think that uh you described Ethan
Klein. I think lefties are crazy. I
think the pro Palestinian side is crazy.
And I think I could probably find more
evidence for these people. I think that
Israel is bad, but it's not as bad as
it's being categorized as. And I think
generally speaking, you should be nice
to Jews. Um, so realistically, you I
haven't sued anybody into silence. Um,
but you should still probably hate me
about 20% as much as you hate Ethan
Klein based off of that rationale. So,
uh, yeah, just because we're speaking
calmly doesn't mean we agree with each
other.
>> Um,
>> so,
>> yeah. Sure. Sure. I I don't think I I
don't think I hate you 20% as much as I
hate Ethan Klein, but sure. Yeah. Um
>> Okay. Well, that's fine. That's probably
good. The Okay, so we kind of got to uh
Keles's Anna in line and doxing. Are
there any other reasons why you can
think of why you hate Destiny? Great.
>> And then do you think uh sorry, second
part of the question um second part of
the question is these are the top three
reasons that you gave me for why you
hate Destiny. Um, do you feel like your
conduct on the internet for the past two
years has been proportional to his sins?
>> Um, so yeah, another reason why I hate
Destiny. Uh, he took Sugar and Spice
away from us.
>> Okay.
>> So, I assume you know what Sugar and
Spice was. I assume you know.
>> Yes. It's
>> Pixie Podcast.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And there hasn't been an
episode in over a year and a half,
Connor, if you can believe it. There
hasn't been a single a single episode
>> in over a year and a half.
>> And I I could not be more angry. I could
not be more angry.
>> Okay.
>> So, I I do think
>> I I I feel like that's partially
sarcastic and partially earnest.
>> Well, yeah, but it's uh you know, I'm
obviously entailing the the underlying
behavior that caused that to be the case
as part of that.
>> Yes. So,
>> yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Oh, okay. So, so
Pixie would be unironically one of the
ones that you dislike.
>> Yeah, I would say Pixie and everything
that's wrapped up in that. I I wouldn't
necessarily put Pixie Pixie alone, you
know, if if let's let's imagine because
Destiny has already admitted to sharing
news without cons without consent in the
past. He already in the Bob 7 manifesto
admits to doing that. Uh so that was
already publicly known that that he has
done or would do that.
>> Um not not really controversial to say.
Um,
>> so how does I I heard you mention that
uh previously as well with the Bob 7
manifesto. Um, so in reference to that
like uh you know the Bill Cosby joke is
popping into my head of like you know I
think the worst part was the hypocrisy.
Um but the my my question for that is
like I think you've pointed out that
what hold on I I'll sweep for Destiny
real quick. So for Bob 7, uh, he used
his booking job and in order to get in
the ears of all these women, Yeah.
>> pit them against each other, talk [__]
about each other, etc., etc., and then
send dudes without uh people's consent
or whatever. Um, so how do you view
Steven as hypocritical in that regard if
um
if that was the criticism that destroyed
Bob 7's career? Well, I mean, that's
Destiny
does like there's a clip of him
literally laying out in no uncertain
terms it's unethical to try and try and
get with the women you're booking for.
Um, that's basically it. It's I don't
understand that where the line would be
between what Bob 7 did and what what he
does with his stream. Obviously, I think
he said he doesn't really believe that
anymore. Um, and I don't know that I
believe it as a as a hard rule even, but
that that is absolutely I would say
there's no way around the the hypocrisy
there. Um, and I think What about the
arguments that you need to make if
you're going to do that sort of thing?
And and Destiny does not make any of
those considerations.
>> So, so this is a this is a descriptively
true statement. Um, and this is why I'm
not going to become a snarker who
endlessly obsessively stalks Destiny.
Uh, not that you're stalking him
physically. I'm just saying like
>> I I reject even that characterization. I
feel like I should be firmer on this.
The idea that I'm just totally obsessed
with Destiny. I don't cover him that
much at this point. There was a long
long stretches where I'm just not
covering him. Only recently because he's
gone so [__] crazy at me and people
around me have I started covering him
again. Like basically
>> should I sweep for you by pulling up
your uh video?
>> Please. I'll always accept sweeping
>> your your your video uh compilation
because I will I will say that part of
the
accusations against you
are reliant upon your obsessive desire
to destroy Destiny. Um, but it does look
like you not not only does your video
diet have a substantial amount of
diversity, but it seems like gaming I
I'll literally list all the creators
that I see. Okay, I got Techone, Noah
Samson, Hutch, Nick Dioro, Ethan Klein
and Destiny, me,
Destiny, Ethan Klene, uh, Beckett, Nick
Dioro, Teone. So, it seems like if we
were actually to break down a lot some
Gaming for Hope stuff, some Chibi
reviews, some Chud Logic, some more Nick
Dioro, uh, if I was just to take your
past six months to a year, it looks like
you hate Nicholas Dioro substantially
more than you hate Destiny. Or at least
you're giving him substantially more
coverage.
>> Yeah. Yeah, definitely. My way more
coverage than Nick Fioro. I don't I
don't know where I would rank them in
terms of how much I hate them, but
absolutely I, you know, spend way more
time talking about thinking about
Nicolasio. uh making concept. That's
absolutely the case.
>> Did Did you back off on Destiny because
he was threatening to dox you or was it
or content or both? Like like what what
math would you put in there?
>> I'd say there's always an element where
it's like, you know, you don't want to
be on super hot, tense, dangerous
sometimes situations for a huge amount
of time. And if you if you can sort of
uh take a path of least resistance, some
it is easy to do that. And that that's
appealing sometimes, but I wouldn't say
it was determinative in any way. I would
say it's like, you know, it's just like
a it's a consideration. The idea that,
you know, you might get some [__]
insane [__] happen to you. It's like
it's in the back of your mind when
you're thinking about what to cover. But
it was never like sort of determinative.
I'm not going to cover this cuz what if
this happens? It's it's always
>> This might be a weird question and you
can say no comment, but have you been
doxed at this point?
>> No comment. I address the fire.
>> Okay. Um
Okay. [__] Well, all right then. I I
suppose we should get back to E Is
Israel real quick. So, part of the
narrativization that I saw in the video
that I'm not going to straw man. So, we
articulated why Ethan Klein should be
disliked. We articulated probably why
Israel should be disliked. We
articulated why you specifically don't
like Destiny. Um, so is your argument
that there is a intentional
Zionist narrative uh in the internet or
do you think people are picking up on it
subconsciously
and therefore it's like aligned
interest? What what do you think is the
balance between that?
>> Um, sorry. So you're you're basically
saying is it is it conspiracy or just
like aligning?
Yeah. Let's say there was MSAD calling
Destiny and calling Ethan Klein and
giving them $50,000 a year in order to
sweep for Israel in cash. Uh and then
let's say there was well, you know,
Israel's just kind of in the zeitgeist
and most people think that if you hate
Jews too much then you're anti-Semitic.
Therefore, I'm going to kind of go with
the flow. Uh between those two
perspectives, where do you kind of line
up the EI Israel comments that you were
making in your video? It's um so
I'm not alleging
or even I don't even believe in or
suggest or anything any more
coordination than is basically entirely
publicly viewable. Um you can see Dan
Sortman published an article with the
free press. That is Dan Sman working
with the the massive Zionist machine.
That is that is Barry Weiss's paper.
That is him going there to write an
article about Alied and Tan. That is
very clearly Dan using the Zionist
infrastructure in America to push his
own interests. That is what is happening
there. Just know if ants or buts about
it. Same with when Dan goes to say the
ADL, Richie Torres tries to put pressure
on Twitch to get people banned for the
Sabra Hermus.
>> Is Richie Torres a congressman?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I believe so. Congressman.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Um, yeah. I I saw I saw him
tweeting about Assan a few times, but I
didn't see him otherwise. Uh, so so hold
on. So, so from Dan's perspective
though, let let's say that you're you're
Dan real quick, or I'm Dan, and I say,
"Well, I was raised Jewish. I was raised
in the synagogue. My kids are Jews.
They're raised in the synagogue. I buy
into the narrative that Israel is the
fallback point. God forbid there's like
an American Holocaust." And so as a
result, while maybe I don't like
everything that's happening in the West
Bank or, you know, southern Lebanon or
Gaza, I still think that we need like,
you know, may maybe a little bit of
ethnic cleansing, like ethnic cleansing
as a treat. Uh so I still need to
support this Zionist machine because
it's in the existential interest of me
and my family. Uh therefore, not only am
I a Zionist, but I'm also going to work
with other Zionists. How do you feel uh
about that? like, you know, I'm
presuming an internal monologue, but how
do you feel about that internal
monologue?
>> I don't I don't like um
so I'm trying to figure out how to like
pass this out, how to like separate
these things.
>> I don't have like it doesn't sort of
like how I say to you like I expect you
to hate a son. You're a neocon. I don't
have this huge hate for someone who
believes a thing and is playing the the
game within the rules to get there. I
don't have like this huge hate for that.
When I say that the comment about the
machine and it all using each other's
interests, that is almost like entirely
descriptive in that part, you know. It's
like, yeah, that they are kind of going
to do that. Um, but people will deny
that that's what's being done. And
that's sort of like where I get more
annoyed is is the idea that people
suggest that people are are acting like
all this stuff is like uh totally
organic or that actually you know the
the the pro Israel side are the the
underdogs or some stupid [__] like that.
Um, and that's where I start getting
annoyed with what's being said because
it's like
>> how do you how do you feel about the
narrative underdog or the underdog
narrative
>> in reference to so for instance like um
I read a book called Israel the startup
nation. It was literally in a business
class and it it's effectively a
narrativization
of the entrepreneurial spirit of the
Jewish people that was necessary during
the formation of the country in the
40s50s and60s where you know you could
argue they uh stole intellectual
property but what the is uh what the
Israelis would say is that they were
almost a pariah state that was incapable
of developing uh their technology
because they just literally didn't have
it and so stealing intellectual property
because they were prohibited because
they were a pariah state and then
reverse engineering that technology was
necessary to the creation of their state
and then I think they did get their [__]
kicked in. Um obviously like 40 48 was
pretty spicy
>> and then it was
not playing this is what I mean though.
So this is sort of same sort of thing
that I take issue with Dan for is then
you're not playing the game within the
rules like yes you're a prize state
because you should have been a prize
state because you were a settler
colonial project and you were that's the
way you were being treated and you were
uh yeah if you're stealing intellectual
property that's that's wrong. Well, I
mean, I don't even know how much I care
about intellectual property, but in
theory, if you're playing with the
rules,
>> you that's wrong, and you shouldn't.
>> So, how do you deal with the how do you
deal with their moral system, then? It's
like, well, okay, you're going to
prohibit us number one, from existing,
but number two, from breaking the rules.
So, why would we listen to you about the
rules? Um,
well, yeah, I mean, ultimately you have
to you have to enforce it, right? But
it's because I mean there's still the um
this there's a difference between sort
of like the the moral argument and how
you stop them from doing it, right?
Because obviously they're not going to
stop if they're not going to stop, but
they should it should still be enforced.
>> Well, so just as an example,
a private Jewish gentleman, this was one
of the stories in the book. um uh Israel
was prohibited uh internationally from
buying commonly available commercial
airliners.
And so what they did is they found an
American Jew who was sympathetic to the
state of Israel. They bought a
commercial airplane because private
American citizens are willing to do so.
Then they flew through some kind of
airspace because there was like, you
know, prohibited airspace where if they
were found out to be shipping it to
Israel, then they probably would have
been like escorted by American military
uh back to a a base, but the they took
like a a devious route, then they
arrived with a commercial airliner, and
then they reverse engineered the
commercial airliner. Now, for me, it's
like if I had to choose between
existence and breaking a rule, I'm
obviously going to break the [__]
rule. And a and a commercial airliner is
not as malevolent as like military
technology, right? So, so I guess my
question is like um does that hold any
credence or do you just think they
should have like rolled over and died?
>> Yeah, basically
>> as a nation state.
>> Yeah, I think basically they should have
rolled over and died. Yeah, I think the
whole thing's wrong. So, yeah, I mean
ideally they would just roll over and
die. Okay. But all right, that that's
fine. I I'm asking this question not
because I don't know the answer, but
because I just want to hear it out loud.
Um, you could understand how Zionists
would be like, "Okay, well, [__] Queman
then, right?" Yeah. Yeah, obviously.
Okay.
>> All right. Just Just double checking.
Just double checking cuz sometimes
people criticize Israel and then when
the [__] Zionists come back and they
say some spicy [__] everybody gets
their [__] feelings hurt. So, I just
wanted to
>> leave it out there.
>> They just can't go that.
>> How do you feel about the charges?
Sorry. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Not bad. Go for it. ever.
>> I was going to say, how do you feel
about the charges of anti-semitism where
for instance like Ethan Klein would
identify himself as a anti-ionist, but
leftists would call him a liberal
Zionist because he still wants a
two-state solution with frozen borders
and the existence of the nation state of
Israel? Uh, [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] [__] God damn it. I was
laying that out for an argument, but it
was Oh, okay. Anti anti-semitism. So, um
I think that Ethan Klein, uh based off
of polling that I've seen is between
like that perspective, uh 40% of people
identify as Zionist where there's some
level of expansionist in reference to
the state of Israel. Uh I think another
like 47% don't identify with the term of
Israel, but they support the nation
state's existence. So if you add those
two categories together, it's like
between 80 and 87%. Ex uh support the
existence of the nation state of Israel.
So how do you feel about the notion that
if you want to evaporate the nation
state of Israel, you're anti-Semitic
because you're criticizing something
that 87% of Jews believe in?
>> Yeah, I think that's [__] [__]
>> I think that's totally [__] [__]
I just don't think that, you know, the
it's not that that's not how you
determine whether something's
anti-semitic. Anti-semitic refers to
whether it, you know, just because Jews
believe something, you disagree with
that belief or you hate that belief,
that does not mean that you hate Jews or
hate it because it is Jewish, right?
That that's what it comes down to when
you're determining whether something's
anti-semitic. So, yeah, I don't buy the
anti-ionism, anti-semitism stuff at all.
For me, it's not the uh it's not the
label that matters because I think that
the the label anti-semitic is used too
often to dis to dismiss the sentiment
behind the criticism. So if somebody
said, "Oh, I'm not anti-semitic, but I
do want the nation state of Israel to
evaporate." And then a Jew says, "Oh,
well that's anti-Semitic." Then I would
say, "Hey, let's just like work with
what we want in the world in order to
debate what we think is correct." I
wouldn't care about a distinction
between anti-ionism and anti-semitism as
long as we all understood what we were
talking about.
>> Sure. Yeah. It's a semantics game. So, I
agree with that.
>> Okay. Um, realistically, man, I could
probably milk it a little bit more and
uh, you know, just be like, Destiny's a
bad guy. He should die. Uh, but but
that's what I have. That that's what I
had for tonight. I figured
uh because I do not think you were a
stupid person. I think sometimes you go
hard in the paint too hard and might say
some things that I disagree with or I
think are incorrect, but I don't think
you're an unintelligent person. Uh so I
had a feeling that when you started
alluding to the aligned interest of e
Israel,
uh you weren't the Nazi stereotype that
you were being portrayed as. So that
that's the reason why I wanted to have
this conversation.
>> Sure. Um, I mean some of that is, you
know, I I do I am leaning leaning in. I
almost want that reaction. You I almost
want Hutch to call me a Nazi. Obviously,
I feel like that that may come across
like that's you when these retards freak
out at at nothing. It's like that that's
like a good thing to me. That's like the
way you should play it. I don't know if
you've got any thoughts on that. It's
all like similar to that's an
interesting question right there. I've
heard so you want
>> I've heard you referring to that they
are the jokes that were made about
Hutch's sister um as like antisocial and
too far. Um I don't know how exactly you
feel but to me that's like within the
bounds of what happens online that is
like edgy online. Uh
>> it's 100% it's 100% within the bounds of
what happens online. But I want to
explain something that that I think I
articulated during that video.
>> Chill guy for it. So for me, if I had a
friend who was doing that, u I have a
couple of I have dogs who have died on
me in the past, right? They they were
older, they got cancer.
And so if one of my friends wants to be
irreverent and he goes, "Well, you know,
Connor's still brokenhearted over his
dead dog. What a [__] pussy." If his
job is to like razle me and, you know,
hurt my feelings, but do it in a way
where he's [__] with me, but he's
trying to tell me he's he loves me.
Yeah, no problem. That happens every
single [__] day. But if his intention
is to literally get me depressed so I
[__] you know, start drinking or
kill myself.
>> So yeah, I heard you say this. Yeah. I
don't think that's the intention. I
don't think people are trying to make
Hutch kill himself. I don't think that's
what people are trying to do at all.
>> Um,
>> are you for real?
>> I'm for real. I don't think people are
trying to make Hutch kill himself. I
don't think that's what's happening
whatsoever. I don't think they showed up
and being like, "Hey, man, you killed
your dead sister." You don't think
that's them, you know, trying to [__]
get
>> I don't even know who that I So, the
timeline has been like butchered a bit
here. Hutch said that someone in that
discord said his sister was a valid
target and then like 5 minutes later,
someone came into his chat spamming
about his sister. But my understanding
is these were actually like the that
message and someone going into his chat
were like two weeks apart. It was
actually like 12 days later. and the the
mood in the discord. There was a poll
taken about whether there should be
jokes about Hutch's sister and it was
six and 0. No, there shouldn't be jokes
against about Hutch's sister. So, at the
time, the mood was no, don't do that.
Don't do that. Don't do that. Now, later
on, now that Hutch is freaked out about
it and Perry made this video where he's
talking about turning Arch's sister into
a desk. Yes, it's become it's become
almost funny in retrospect because there
has been this freakout over it. That and
that becomes the joke. that becomes more
gives it.
>> But when you Okay. What I'm not going to
buy Okay. What What I'm not going to buy
is that you are uh harassing. You are
harassing I guess. Uh somebody is
harassing Hutch out of love. I I I don't
think
>> No, they're not doing it. But why does
why does it have to be either out of
love or trying to make him kill himself?
People don't like him. They're ripping
on him and said trying to make funny
jokes about him. The the like make him
look bad or hurt his feelings because
they don't like him. But that is not
trying to make him kill himself. That
like the idea.
>> Okay. What What are Hutch's sins?
>> Hutch's sins. What are Hutch's sins? He
Hutch I really I really do dislike Hutch
and Wig. I'm going to be and I think I
have perfectly valid reasons. I think
you know if you really had your eyes
open, you would see them, too. They are
both very dishonest and very stupid.
that it's like and they get given
>> what what is a
>> way too much grace.
>> Hold on.
>> So, hold on. Doobie says, and I don't
agree with them on this at all,
>> that Hutch was lying about Ogre Boy
jumping into the Discord to check if
people were harassing his dead sister.
That That's what he said, that Hutch was
knowingly lying. But what I got from the
same piece of content, which I probably
watched twice, uh, because I actually
really liked, uh, Hutch being vulnerable
and sharing stuff about his sister, um,
the what I got from that was he was
saying that Ogre Boy made it sound like
he jumped into the Discord on a tear and
was like, "You guys better not be
[__] doing this, right?" But if you
look at what was actually sent in the
Discord,
>> I wouldn't point to that. I wouldn't
point to that as an example at all. Um,
so
>> okay. So, so what is what else has Hutch
lied about?
>> So there's there's a very clear example.
I don't you know I'm reticent to use
this one because I don't want to make
the anti-destiny circle joke. They won't
expect it to be. Um, but that there's
the very obvious one is Hutch initially
takes a very strong moral stance about
what Destiny did stuff. That's what
happens when it first breaks. Later on
he makes a statement saying he's seen
new details in the case that make it all
a lot more gray. then denies he said
that and uh basically says uh all that
all he said was a statement about how um
oh I was I was an addict and I
understand people can can change and do
bad things when they're in a state of
addiction all this sort of stuff but
that's not that wasn't all that he said
he made a specific statement that things
had changed in the case which I don't
understand what could have changed in
the case that would change your moral
analysis based on the things that he had
said previously and he is he refuses to
explain that and he denied that it
happened. So that's that's like a clear
point where I feel like he just he just
lied. He just lied and it was just
because he didn't want to get heat for
the association, you know, and I don't I
don't care about the association in and
of itself,
>> but you got to be you got to be real
about it. Don't don't take the strong
moral line and refuse to explain why
it's changed. That's that's [__]
That's snake behavior. the Okay, so the
reason why I'm sympathetic to Hutch and
I wouldn't accuse him of a lie of
commission unless I actually had the
specific things was because in you were
and lab and Mr. girl and a shitload of
other people
>> wanted strong denunciations.
>> Huge.
>> What's that?
>> Wanted strong denunciations. Is that
what you're going to say?
>> Yes. Yeah. That that that's a that's a
polite way to put it.
>> Um so
>> yeah, for sure.
>> In 24 to4 Yeah. In within 72 hours of
the January 20th, 2020
five drama,
there were there was a huge wave of
anger in order for creators to distance
themselves from Stephen. And uh I think
I told you to go [__] yourself. That was
fun.
>> I mean, it didn't even So again, I have
to push back that I'm not I don't say
people have to disassociate. things I
say are that if you have standards for
association that you've laid out, you
should stick to them or actually
articulate why they've changed other
than you just not sticking to them out
of self-interest. Okay, that's that's
the first thing.
>> What is what Okay, hold on. Hold on. Let
Let me ask you a question. What is
worse?
Uh what is worse? sharing homemade
pornography without consent and
allegedly audio recording uh sexual
encounters that were consensual but
without the consent of the other parties
or being a lollycon pedophile.
>> Uh the first one wait
a pedophile that only looks at lollycon
but is a pedophile. Is that what you're
saying?
>> Yeah, sure. Uh what do you call it? Um
>> like a a virtual like a noble pedophile.
>> A virtuous pedophile. That's what I call
it. Yeah.
>> A virtuous pedophile. Yeah. Yeah. Which
one's worth the virtual?
>> I would say I would say the one who
actually does the person who actually
does the whole act the person who
actually does the whole act would be the
first one. It would be the first one to
me.
>> Okay,
that's fine.
>> So So yeah, food shops is not as bad as
Destiny in my in my world view.
>> Really?
>> Yeah, food shops is not as bad as
Destiny. Also, food shops has less
agency. She's like legit disabled. It's
like,
>> you know.
>> Oh, wait. Sorry. That might be really
funny. Can you Can you say that again?
What? You said she does have agency or
doesn't have
>> doesn't have a lot of agency. No, no,
no.
>> Okay. So, so you just think she's like a
a leaf blowing in the wind. She just
goes where her
>> Yeah.
>> Sorry. Okay. So, so one of the things is
like the
once again, I don't hate Stephen. Not
going to go out of my way to [__] with
him. Not going to be joining the
Snarkers in their crusade. Uh, but you
know, obviously something that there was
tension over was the association with
food shops. That was a huge tension.
>> So, I'm not
I'm not pulling punches anymore. That
[__] that [__] says something about
me, I'm going pedophile.
>> I saw you on Twitter earlier. I saw you
going forth.
>> Every time Every time she mentions me,
pedophile. That That's what I'm going to
say. I I don't have to [__]
I'm not going to pull punches just
because you're Steven's strongest
soldier. Like, that is not a thing.
>> Yeah. No, no, that was uh that was that
was awesome. Like seeing that. That was
pretty cool.
>> Um
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. So, we were I was saying I I
really dislike
>> Hutch and Wick. So, that was one example
of Hutch being incredibly dishonest.
Another point where I felt like Hutch
has been quite dishonest and quite
>> Hold on real quick real real quick. Real
real quick. People are criticizing you
because they're saying that you give
zero [__] about Lollcon. Obviously, I
have like a different opinion. But then
Stephen, the very conversation that I'm
referencing where I said, "Hey, I think
you associating with food shops is a
mistake and it's bad. Here's why." And
then he was like, "Well, I think it's
just drawings." And I was like, "Fucking
kill me." So anyways, sorry. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So another reason why I felt
Hutch quite dishonest and stupid. Uh I
don't know if you saw his arguments with
Pisco over the Ethan Klein stuff or his
argument with Straight Arid. You didn't
feel, sorry, I'm jumping ahead a little
bit. You didn't feel like Pisco, like I
understand Pisco was being pretty or
Hutch was being pretty abrasive towards
Pisco in one conversation that I saw the
You don't think Pisco is abrasive in
[__] general?
>> Neither that I'm not talking about
abrasiveness whatsoever. That Pisco is
abrasive.
>> Nothing to do with being abrasive. Hutch
is in He's like so condescending. It's
not abrasive. It is like pulling faces
at everything that's said instead of
giving an argument. And it's so [__]
weak. It is genuinely worst like stream
debate uh demeanors that I've ever had
the displeasure of watching. Um
>> is that because Pisco wouldn't let Hutch
crucify Taylor Loren's
>> um
>> sufficiently?
>> That that Lib episode is pretty bad too.
That was pretty bad.
>> Okay.
>> Um, but no, it's specifically the the
ones about the Ethan Klein stuff. It was
it was like they had a super long debate
about I think the Ethan Klein lawsuits
and Hutch basically never um he like
almost never argues. He does basically
just like uh beg the question repeatedly
like go he does constantly the CPS and
Skoles thing. He's constantly like they
they sent CPS and Skulls to his house.
They sent CPS and Skulls to his house.
And there's just no way that I don't
believe anyone who's doing that sort of
argumentation doesn't real has been in
this space for this long and doesn't
realize how that's like totally
non-responsive and and they're basically
just doing a tactic there. They're like
trying to get out of arguing the point.
>> Do you have any regrets?
I I know you probably don't run the
Discord yourself. Uh, do you have any
regrets of the optics of having Skulls
with CPS on it for the Discord banner?
>> No.
>> No. Okay. I think I think that's a good
>> Did anybody to your knowledge in the
Discord uh participate in the the
[__] the Have you ever you know the
doxing, spotting, skulls, CPS calls? Is
anybody in the Discord that you know of
uh engaged in that activity or admitted
to engaging in that activity in the
past?
>> Not to my knowledge. Not to my
knowledge. Obviously, they could have.
I've got I don't Everyone's I was I'm
sorry. I know like you know Shimu has
doxed in the past Destiny dug up the
other day. Shimoo doxed people like
three or four years ago when he was part
of these um what is it? Vector troll
groups like Ethan Ralph sort of area,
you know, troll groups that that were
fighting on Discord, doxing each other.
Um, there's like stuff like I'm sure
there are people like that who have done
stuff in the past. A lot of people have
doxed in the past, but to my knowledge,
there's no there's this isn't a behavior
that's being exhibited by this group um
or pe people in it. And when it is when
it is exhibited the moment you can show
this person did this they're dealt with
and it's it's dealt with.
>> Is there is there any platform
uh excuse me is there any offplatform
enforcement of doxing or is it solely on
the server to your knowledge? So
I
have recently
enforced against some offplatform
conduct. uh the one that was brought up
from the server and there was a separate
one that happened on Twitter by user in
the server and I I took action in my uh
community because of those offplatform
behaviors. Um, which I don't really like
doing because it does feel like you
start making a rod for your own back
that the moment you get into moderating
off platform, you're taking on this
insurmountable task where you're
expected to keep going. And it's like
the moment you don't do it for someone,
it's like, why aren't you doing it for
that person? You want them to get doxed
and then they almost try and put
responsibility on it now. And it's like
it feels like you're just play you get
that's the goal almost to get you
wrapped up into this endless game of of
trying to ban
a bunch of users.
>> The the argument though the argument
though from the anti snarkers or the
giggers though is that like even though
this was a not private discord or
private discord of a hundred people that
they would be if they were previous
doxers or people who had ga engaged in
personal identifying operations in the
past uh they would effectively know not
to make that public. uh ergo, you might
[__] talk somebody in the general, but
then because DMs are obviously closed
and if all these people have incentives
because they're all doing equally bad
[__] the only way to find the kind of
evidence that I'm looking for uh is if
somebody uh turn coats and then
screenshots and leaks DMs. That that
that's like the and I'm sympathetic to
that argumentation. Um I just think that
if you're going to dock somebody, you
should probably have something. So, so
what do you say to the fact that like
uh because I almost guarantee you this
is gonna be Dan and Destiny's argument
is that you got most of you 95% of you
are smart enough not to dox in VC or in
the text channels but if you wanted to
engage in P ops or gay ops you would
just coordinate the [__] talking in the
server but then you would just jump into
a group call for the gay ops or pops
>> it's just like a totally unfalsifiable
claim that you can say about literally
any community online. Um like there you
literally can't go anywhere online
without running into someone who has
done some form of doxing or something
someone would consider to be doxing in
the past. It's like it's that there
especially in these communities. It's
like it is literally impossible to vet
for no one who has ever done anything
like this or that could be argued to be
like this. So all it is it just comes
off like a totally unfalsifiable claim
that it's like it is just a blank check.
It's just a blank check. It's
>> So if if um I asked Dubie a similar
question. So if let's say that
because I I try to earnestly engage with
people and I often feel like people
earnestly engage with me because of my
earnestness, but that doesn't mean that
people are incapable of lying. So, let's
say that uh the manifesto comes out or
some Discord DMs come out and there's
something here in the never have I ever
questionnaire, which I know is a grill,
but you just like baldface lie to me. Do
do you have any problems with me
disassociating and saying, "Hey,
>> I tried to be earnest with Queen
>> and he was not earnest with me,
therefore [__] him."
>> No, of course not. If if I straight of
course if I straight up lied to you
about what I was engaging, of course, I
expect you to dissociate with me. That
would that would make total sense.
>> Okay. The the the only reason why I want
that articulated is because it's like if
the if the manifesto drops because this
is what DGG is saying right now. They're
saying trust Destiny. Trust Destiny.
Trust the plan. Trust the plan. Trust
the plan. He's working on the manifesto.
He's working on the manifesto. But what
they're acting like is that they're
going to get the smoking gun of you or
Jtock or Doobie engaged in malicious
antisocial behavior that is worthy of
disassociation. And it's also going to
prove that you're snarkers or whatever.
Not just snarkers, but like uh malicious
digital harassers.
>> Yeah.
>> So uh but what I'm expecting and I'll be
happy to eat crow on this. I would
prefer it if I ate Crow on this. What's
going to happen is because a Discord is
so large, there's going to be similar
things like uh Wix PII floating around
or whatever the [__] was happening with
that or there's going to be references
to Hutch's
uh dead sister or something like that.
But we're not gonna get the smoking gun
that says Queman, Jtock, or Doobie are
the uh swatting doxing attempting to
murder Nathan people. So uh yeah, that
that that's what I'm worried about is
effectively it's going to be
inconclusive.
Um, yeah. I just don't know how.
So, how what would you need for it to be
conclusive in the other direction
>> that you guys are not the snarkers?
>> Yes. That we're that we're not doing
anything that's, you know, that that
we're keeping all of our
>> Weirdly enough, I thought Snark uh was
going to hate me for stating this. Uh,
and sorry, re real quick. This one's
important.
Uh, X Belovecat says, "Ask if anyone has
mass reported. We already know that
Jtock did, but Jtock did
>> in he's claiming self-defense because uh
Destiny based on that chronology had
already called for his docs at that
point.
>> So is there any other mass reporting
besides the Jtock mass report that you
know of?
>> So yeah, one one user it's not I don't
know if it's quite mass reporting. I
what I'm aware of is one user and this
what I took action on in my community.
One user tagged team YouTube under a
tweet uh of Loner Box telling Hassan to
kill himself. Um and like that's it's
not quite mass reporting. Um I don't
know if I would usually take action in
all cases for something like that. Uh
however, because I have a relationship
with Loner Box. I just literally I don't
I don't want even, you know, the risk or
appearance of risk that someone's going
to go after his channel for being too
close. It's just like it creates [__]
problems. Um, I can't obviously hunt
down everyone that's ever made an
erroneous report or an erroneous at team
YouTube in my community, but when it
comes up with people that I might be
associating with that, you know, it's
just [__] annoying. It's just like a
problem.
>> Yeah. La last liberal, I don't know if
you were in here earlier, but I have
evidence that there was a I'm not even
looking for evidence. I just found
evidence. Somebody gave it to me that
there was a Telegram group chat of
Gropers who wanted to kill Destiny and
were trying to hype up one of their
members in order to finally doing it.
And so my question is logically if this
group of gripers were ready, willing,
and able to try to hype each other up
for somebody to go kill Destiny in
Miami, then why wouldn't they do
swatting and doxing? And I have evidence
of this. I have screenshots of this. So
I have pres at this point, at this
juncture, once again, I am praying to be
totally wrong. I'm praying that we have
a three-way a four-way conversation
between Chudlo Logic, [__] Queman,
Jtock, and Doobie. And they're like,
"Connor's such a [__] idiot. I can't
believe he's falling for this. We are
currently mass raping Destiny online,
and he's such an idiot. I can't believe
that he's buying our bullshit." Maybe
we'll find that. Uh, but if we don't
find that, then what? because I have
more evidence of those people that are
likely to swat Destiny than Destiny,
Dan, Lonerbox, Hutch, or Wick have
presented.
So,
I have evidence. You show me yours.
>> Um,
>> all right. Sorry. So, so yeah, we were
saying what what would need what would
you need to be conclusive in the we're
innocent direction or at least I'm
innocent always so
>> yeah that count
>> I think it's a I think it's like a one
it's a time thing two I think Destiny
would basically have to gay op
infiltrate the Snarker Discord so he
would have to hire some Indians
uh part-time full-time you know give
them $10,000 a year to
>> infiltrate your guy's [__] snarker
servers and then you be active
participants who are beloved in the
community and then see if you guys offer
them any OENT tools or doxing tools or
whatever. It would basically like a
long-term undercover mission.
>> Sure.
>> And if the undercover mission didn't
yield any fruit after like a year, then
I'd be like, "Okay, they're clean."
>> So,
>> um so so there's there's nothing really
reasonable that can be done to to show
um
>> you know, at least that this is highly
highly improbable.
Well, and see this is part of the reason
why I was beefing with Destiny on Friday
was because
the assertion the the assertion is your
absolute guilt. Jtock's guilty. Quan's
guilty. Doobie's guilty. They deserve to
be digitally ostracized and ignored.
That's what they deserve. Uh and they
deserve to be doxed. And yet when I say,
"Okay, well, what have they done?" The
answer is they cumulatively
contributed to a permission structure in
which people could dox and swat Destiny
by talking [__] about him on the
internet.
And by that virtue, I am guilty of the
same thing for Hassan [__]
So Hassan [__] like based off of that
rationale, Hassan [__] should be able
to dox me,
>> which he did, by the way. But but but
like that but then based off of that I
should be trying to dox Hassan. But I'm
not going to because he can dox me but
I'm I think the internet should be the
internet. So my job is to talk [__]
about him on the internet.
That's where I'm at right now. Maybe
>> I agree. I b that's that's what I agree
with. That's what I'm uh pushing hard
right now. That's why I feel like, you
know, why it's why I feel like it's
worth attacking Ethan Klein and and
Destiny separately. Um, you know, I feel
like that they are probably some of the
biggest purveyors that I know of uh of
of the falling standards of the
degradation of
like the ability for us to do this.
>> This is actually like one of the first
uh smart chats that I've seen all night.
So, what one of the accusations is that
uh key there there's Kiwi Farms
crosspollination.
And for me,
I I kind of sarcastically use your guys
excuses of, oh, well, it's just a drama
forum and they prohibit harassment, so
realistically that's the best that it's
going to get. Regardless of whether or
not Kiwi Farm should or shouldn't exist,
the it does feel pretty weak to have the
documented sins of an online personality
in one convenient place for them to read
and then also to have their name,
address, telephone number, current
employer and family members and then to
say we are not encouraging
>> digital I don't I don't you know I don't
know that it should be illegal to have
the doc information there in the way
that Q forms does. I don't I don't know
that I agree with that. You know, there
are some I have a lot of sympathy for
the idea of anti-docing laws. I I think
I agree with making some forms of doxing
illegal, especially when coupled with uh
otherwise criminal harassment like
California does. Um my my issue my issue
in my defense of Kiwi Farms is is that
you should make that illegal, not try
and get the website taken off or shut
down or whatever. you know, as long as
if they're operating within the law,
they should be allowed to operate, you
know, that you shouldn't shouldn't go
and [__] with them because
>> then follow-up question. Uh, this might
this might put you in a bind. So, if no
comment is, uh, the answer, that's fine.
>> But, uh, in the past or going forward,
if there was, as a matter of fact, this
might actually just be a good good, uh,
testing of principle. So to your
knowledge, if if somebody was found to
have not done it in the server but
posted personal identifying information
to Kiwi Farms uh and we knew who that
person was, they they used like similar
handles or some [__] like that, would
that person uh have been doxed in or not
doxed, excuse me, would person have been
doxed from JStock server or would it
have been viewed as like offplatform
behavior and therefore not your concern?
Um,
if there's someone So, you're saying if
there's someone within these communities
that has a Kiwi Farms or post doxing on
Kiwi Farms, would they be allowed to
stay?
>> Yeah. Wasn't there um who I don't know
if you'd be able to remember this just
off of this description. Wasn't there a
pretty famous Kiwi farmer that Destiny's
mentioned by name
that was in Jtock's old server, not this
one. Or he was in Spicy Chat. uh he was
in spicy chat and he was banned but he
posted some PII or docs info but he was
using similar handles between Discord
and
>> yeah so there there were like a few
years ago I think there was if it was
just one guy if there were two guys
there there have been people that have
kicked around like that I think my
general stance now is I if I would set a
hard rule I don't like having people
like that kicking around I I don't I I
would if there's someone that I know of
that is in any way an active active
doctor I'm generally just going to
remove them from my community. Period.
>> All right. Well, and then sorry, here's
a question. You don't Do you run that
server or No.
>> Um, no. I I don't run that server. I
don't run that server, but obviously,
you know, I I I'm not going to want I'm
not going to want those people around
me. So, I'm generally going to advocate
against them against them being
anywhere, you know.
>> Okay.
>> And obviously, I'm a content creator in
there. I'm sure my words have like some
some level of weight. I don't know how
much weight they would have, but, you
know, that's
>> Okay. I'm trying I'm trying to think of
that guy's name, but I can't I can't
think of it for the life.
>> I mean, I think it's best if you don't
mention a lot of these guys by name.
That's that's another thing. Yeah, this
something Destiny sites as well is that
I people say like Blav won in my chat.
This is this for the Destiny always.
>> That was it. Although this
>> there he is. We know HIS NAME NOW. BLAV.
>> YEAH. YEAH. I don't I think there was um
I don't know if that's exactly the one
you're because there was
>> you're like it's best that we don't say
his name, but that's why people say
Blav.
>> This is This is the This is This is the
only one I bring up because it's because
Desi has brought him up on stream so
many times. It's like he goes off Desi
and Desi keeps bringing up. You can't
Yeah. It's almost difficult to not to
not have the name kicking around when
he's given so much [__] attention.
It's like
so it becomes difficult at a certain
point.
>> Okay. Well, that is um that's what I
got. What What else do you have?
>> Um what else do I have?
Do I have anything else? Oh. Um, I've
got, you know, I'm not vouching for him,
but Purple Parry did ask me to ask you
to unblock him, and he's sorry for being
gay in DMs, but I I
>> Okay,
>> I don't uh vouch for him in any way. I
don't co-sign him, so uh
>> So, so what happened was he was like,
cuz I I remember this. He was like,
"Let's talk about this."
And I was like, "H I don't want to." Or
I was just like, "Ah, not I'm dizzy
right now." And he's like, "You're gay."
And I was like, "Okay, well, bye." You
know, that that's uh I I'm
It's not that I'm unwilling to talk to
skitsoids. I'm actually quite willing to
talk to skitsoids, but if you're trying
to get my [__] time, at least be
polite about it at first. Holy [__]
>> Uh yeah, he's he's not he's not very
polite. I'll agree with that for sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Jim says he he gave me a super chat and
he really wants me to talk to you about
this. Queen has stated multiple times
that Godzilla minus one is better than
any Clint Eastwood movie. Knowing this,
do you still believe Creman shouldn't be
doxed?
>> So, so is Godzilla minus one better than
any Clint Eastwood movie?
>> Um, yeah. I know I've seen all Clint
Eastwood movies. It is a little bit of a
ragebait comment, but that I I just talk
I I've spoken a few times about how uh
you know, conservatives um don't even
appreciate uh movies that that do
actually have conservative values when
they come out. They just totally ignore
them. Now we talk about uh and so I rate
Godzilla minus one as one of those um
>> a like secretly conservative movie that
conservatives don't even appreciate
>> conservative uh message and tone to it
that I don't think it's appreciated by
them. Yeah.
>> Ah yes. So so somebody says this and
this is actually something I wanted to
ask and I'm happy they reminded me.
Um,
what what is your because it felt like
during your is e Israel speech, what you
were trying to at least what I felt like
you were trying to convey was a sense of
shared danger over the threat to free
speech because Dest if you criticized
Destiny too harshly, if you're too
hyperbolic or if you're too viferous
uh or if you helped people that were too
hyperbolic or too viferous, you would
get docked.
That's obviously going to chill some
speech. And then also the Ethan Klein
suing people over matters of opinion.
That was a another thing that you said
would show free speech. So what what
right are you fighting for? Are are you
fighting for the right to be mean? Are
you fighting for the right to be uh to
digitally harass people? What's the
difference between being mean on the
internet and digital harassment? I
thought the obvious answer here is is
snarking. No, I thought that's the
obvious obvious answer to
>> No, I I mean literally like I looked up
the definition of snarking the other
day.
So So you think that uh Americans andor
Western people should fight for their
right to snark?
>> Uh yeah, that's kind of a a corny way to
put it. But sure. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So snarking definitionally is the act of
making mocking, sarcastic, or
contemptuous comments. It typically
involves a biting, irreverent tone that
blends badteered criticism with a sense
of humor, often aiming to put someone or
something down in a witty or cynical
way.
>> Yeah, I think that's a great definition.
>> Okay.
All right. Is are is it your Well, hold
on.
Is it moral to docks?
>> To docks?
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's legal obviously. You're taking
public information. No, I don't think
Doc and tomorrow will die.
>> Okay. All right. That's what I got.
>> Okay. Well, um
I wonder is is there anything else?
Anyone in chat got anything? Any chat?
Anyone in chat got anything they want to
bring up or they want they want
addressed
before we wrap up here?
Um,
says Mr. Gull apology form.
Listen, I'm not apologizing to Mr. Girl.
Not because uh I
I give the women in Destiny's life more
agency than a lot of snarkers do, or at
least some responsibility. I suppose I
am a victim blamer. I will victim blame
women, but I will also victim blame
destiny. And then what was the other
thing? Mr. Girl, sexual dynamics, clout,
money, influence. Oh, uh, talking about
permission structures, I feel like he
created a very strong permission uh,
structure for non-offending pedophiles.
And so, I mean, you can see that as a
good thing or a bad thing. I don't like
that. So, uh, I will not be apologizing
to Mr. Girl. Um,
okay. Uh,
I thought there was something else, but
I'm
struggling to remember.
>> Oh, did you feel Oh, during your
divorce, did you feel like Neo dodging
your ex-wife's lies or not?
>> No. Okay. Okay. Okay. overshare time.
Uh my ex and I we the one thing that we
we've said harsh words to each other,
that's for sure. But and she said some
harsh things to me and she put some
harsh things in some paperwork. But my
lawyer was a
aggressive lawyer is the way that I
would describe her. and she said, "We're
not getting down into mudslinging where
she's talking [__] about you and then we
talk [__] about her in legal responses.
We're not going to acknowledge them.
We're going to go to mediation and we're
going to negotiate a good deal." And so
by ignoring some of the barbs that I
could have taken personal offense to if
I felt like being sensitive, uh we were
able to get our mediation done in a
single day.
>> Wow.
>> So,
>> awesome stuff. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, so no.
>> Uh she said some mean things, hurt my
feelings a little bit, but I think
that's divorce.
>> Oh, also, um you spoke about I think you
spoke about going out on a date with
someone and there being yellow/ red flag
triggers. Uh Bug wanted to know what
those were.
If we're uh I've only dated two people
since my divorce. So, the person that I
dated
before my current girlfriend, she was
very nice, very ve very cool. She
actually uh she texted me the other day
about something non-romantic.
Um she's a she works for Orlando Health,
not trying to dox or anything. Uh but
she basically does some really good
humanitarian [__] for there. her yellow
red flags for me were the fact that uh
she did talk about some of her previous
relationship trauma. Everybody's got
trauma. That's not that big of a deal.
Um but I think that one of the things
was that she felt like she had to be uh
physically attractive. And when I
mentioned something about like, hey,
we're not going to be able to see each
other for a few days. If you want to
hook up, you know, we would have to do
it at this time. uh she got like
triggered like she felt like I was only
using her because she was uh attractive
and she got really sensitive about it.
And if you're going to get that
sensitive about something that I felt
was like pretty routine like trying to
coordinate logistics to see each other
before a crazy week
or like that relationship we probably
would have tripped other yellow flags or
red flags. Uh, my current girlfriend is
like a a straight green flag. Uh, but I
don't want to sound like I'm coping, so
I'll keep the green flags to myself.
>> Okay. Got you.
>> Got you. Wow. There's There's the answer
then.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> you know what's great about the truth?
>> You don't have to [__] lie about
anything and you don't have to remember
anything.
>> Very true. Facts. Straight facts.
>> Literally, you ask me the question, I
say what's what I think to be true. It's
that simple.
>> Yep. Well, okay. I mean, I feel like
I've got nothing else ever. We're good
here.
>> Um, like we don't want to turn this into
just like a Yeah, snark circle joke. So,
that's fine. Uh, I'm going to go hang
out with my community. I'm actually just
going to go post the Discord. Uh, if any
snarkers
want to come in and talk [__] I might
kick you if you're super rude. But, um,
yeah, we're going to do a community
night over here.
>> All right. Well, thanks for coming and
uh I'll catch you later.
>> See you.
>> Yep.
>> Wow,
what a great chat, guys. What a great
chat.
So, I can't address every like, you
know, tiny implication that you may have
dogs on, bro.
I I just can't. Come on now.
It's not necessary. Totally unneeded.